así como vimos el concepto de mol el
balanceo de ecuaciones es una de esas
ideas que se aprenden en las primeras
clases de química y que a muchos
estudiantes les cuesta mucho trabajo
aprender aún cuando es un concepto
sencillo lo complicado es aplicarlo pero
antes de hablar del balanceo de
ecuaciones químicas que es una ecuación
química aquí les muestro algunos
ejemplos
esencialmente la ecuación química
describe una reacción química aquí
tenemos un poco de aluminio y oxígeno
gaseoso o una molécula t atómica de
oxígeno que producen óxido de aluminio y
bueno esta es la ecuación está muy
bonita
tengo mis reactivos es decir las cosas
que reaccione estos son los reactivos y
luego tengo los productos de la reacción
que me queda por hacer aquí hay un
problema así como está escrita la
reacción me está diciendo que tengo un
átomo de aluminio más dos átomos de
oxígeno verdad una molécula del gas
tiene dos átomos de oxígeno y cuando se
lleva a cabo la reacción me dice que
tengo dos átomos de aluminio y tres
átomos de oxígeno tenemos diferente
número de moléculas en cada lado de la
ecuación química de este lado tengo un
aluminio de este lado tengo dos
aluminios y luego tengo diferente número
de oxígenos en este lado tengo dos
oxígenos y de este lado tengo tres
oxígenos el balanceo de ecuaciones me
sirve para resolver este problema
balanceando podría tener el mismo número
de aluminio en ambos lados de la
ecuación y también el mismo número de
oxígenos lo pondré en otro color
tengo un aluminio aquí y 2 aluminios por
acá entonces lo más fácil es poner un 2
justo aquí así ya tengo 2 aluminios de
este lado y 2 aluminio de este los
aluminios ya están felices ahora veamos
el oxígeno aquí tengo 2 oxígenos del
lado izquierdo de la ecuación y del lado
derecho tengo 3 oxígenos que puedo hacer
aquí puedo tener la mitad de átomos si
simplemente multiplico esto por 3 medios
que es igual a 1.5 así que al
multiplicar esto es igual a 3 ahora
tengo 3 oxígenos en ambos lados de la
ecuación y tengo 2 aluminios en ambos
lados también ya quedó claro no es
lógico tener medio átomo o mejor dicho
un átomo y medio pero lo que se hace es
multiplicar esto para poder tener
números enteros así que podemos
multiplicar ambos lados de la ecuación
por 2
queda 4 aluminios + 3 oxígenos producen
y como multiplicamos todo por 2
aquí nos quedan dos moléculas de óxido
de aluminio
quizás se han confundido en algún punto
y han llegado a pensar oye y por qué no
simplemente pongo que dos tercios
multipliquen nada más a este oxígeno no
se puede la ecuación es como es el óxido
de aluminio es óxido de aluminio no se
puede cambiar la proporción que existe
entre los átomos de aluminio y oxígeno y
alterar adentro de la molécula sólo se
podría cambiar pero si se multiplicará
toda la molécula por un coeficiente es
decir este número que pusimos aquí en
este caso es 2 lo que hicimos fue hacer
que en ambos lados de la ecuación esté
el mismo número de aluminio 2 aluminios
y el mismo número de oxígenos que aquí
al multiplicar por 1.5 nos quedan 3
oxígenos pero como no podemos tener un
número decimal de 1.5 entonces
multiplicamos toda la ecuación química
por 2 con lo que nos quedó 4 aluminios
más 3 moléculas de oxígeno gaseoso
o también seis átomos de oxígeno y se
producen dos moléculas de óxido de
aluminio veamos si podemos hacer más
problemas sobre esto aquí tengo etileno
y lage entre paréntesis es para
especificar que se encuentra en estado
gaseoso etileno gaseoso más oxígeno
gaseoso que produce dióxido de carbono
gaseoso más agua y está l significa en
estado líquido cómo le hacemos aquí yo
les recomiendo que primero hagamos las
moléculas complejas y al final nos
preocupamos por las moléculas compuestas
de un solo acto porque estas son más
fáciles y la razón por la que les digo
esto es porque cuando cambiamos un
número aquí digamos que queremos igualar
el número de carbonos en ambos lados de
la ecuación si yo pongo un número aquí
ese coeficiente también afectaría a este
hidrógeno por lo que tendría que mover
el número de hidrógenos de acá
y al final tendré un número de átomos
con lo que podría establecer un
coeficiente aquí entonces empecemos con
los carbonos parece complicado pero si
nos vamos paso por paso podrán ver que
no es tan difícil entonces aquí hay dos
carbonos y del lado derecho de la
ecuación química hay un carbono
quiero tener dos carbonos en ambos lados
de la ecuación
así que pondré un 2 aquí ahí están mis
carbonos son felices tengo 2 carbonos y
2 carbonos ahora vamos con los
hidrógenos recuerden dejaremos el
oxígeno al final porque podemos poner
cualquier coeficiente que queramos
dependiendo de cuántos oxígenos vamos a
necesitar entonces de este lado de la
ecuación tengo cuatro átomos de
hidrógeno cuántos átomos de hidrógeno
tengo de este lado de la ecuación
bueno pues son dos átomos de hidrógeno y
yo quiero tener
en ambos lados así que pondré un 2 como
coeficiente para el agua así ya tengo
cuatro átomos de hidrógeno
finalmente el oxígeno del lado izquierdo
tengo dos átomos de oxígeno y del lado
derecho que tengo tengo dos por este
oxígeno aquí van dos beta porque tengo
dos moléculas de agua así que son dos
oxígenos en esta molécula luego tengo
dos oxígenos en cada molécula de dióxido
de carbono y hay dos moléculas entonces
cuántos oxígenos tengo aquí cuatro
oxígenos del lado izquierdo
tengo dos oxígenos y del lado derecho
tengo seis oxígenos dos en la molécula
de agua y cuatro en dos moléculas de
dióxido de carbono
o algo que esté 2 se convierte en 6
tengo 6 oxígenos de este lado y quiero
hacer que sean 6 de este otro lado
también simplemente pongo un 3 aquí
ahora ya tengo 6 oxígenos y mi ecuación
ya está balanceada tengo 2 carbonos de
este lado 2 carbonos de este otro lado
tengo 4 hidrógenos de este 6 oxígenos de
este lado y 4 26 oxígenos del otro lado
siguiente ecuación a balancear aquí
tengo están más oxígeno gaseoso
produciendo dióxido de carbono y agua es
un proceso de combustión veamos los
carbonos primero tengo 2 carbonos aquí
un carbono por acá pondré 2 aquí así ya
tengo 2 carbonos recuerden el oxígeno lo
dejamos al final como hicimos en el
problema anterior aquí tengo
hidrógenos y dos hidrógenos en el agua
así que pondré tres moléculas de agua
queda balanceado el hidrógeno ya tengo
seis hidrógenos en ambos lados de la
ecuación y ahora veamos el oxígeno aquí
en el dióxido de carbono lo pondré en
otro color
tengo 2 oxígenos en cada dióxido de
carbono y tengo dos moléculas entonces
tengo 4 oxígenos y tengo un oxígeno por
cada molécula de agua como tengo tres
moléculas 3 oxígenos del lado derecho y
luego tengo 4 oxígenos en el dióxido de
carbono tengo 7 oxígenos en este lado y
sólo tengo 2 de este lado como puedo
convertir este 2 a 7 bueno puedo
multiplicar por 3 y medio
recuerden quiero tener 7 en ambos lados
si tengo 3.5 de esta molécula de atómica
de oxígeno 3.5 por 2 es igual a 7 así me
quedan 7 oxígenos en ambos lados de la
ecuación 2 carbonos y 6 hidrógenos de
terminar excepto por el hecho de que no
podemos tener fracciones en las
moléculas solo hay que multiplicar ambos
lados de la ecuación por 2
o cualquier número por el que se
necesite multiplicar para poder quitar
la fracción si multiplicó todo por dos
me queda dos moléculas de etam más siete
moléculas de oxígeno de atómico siete
votos produciendo
cuatro moléculas de dióxido de carbono
6 moléculas de agua podemos revisar los
cuantos carbonos tengo aquí tengo 4
carbonos y 4 carbonos por acá cuantos
hidrógenos tengo 12 hidrógenos aquí y 12
hidrógenos de este lado cuánto oxígeno
tengo lo pondré de otro color
aquí tengo 14 oxígenos y aquí 8 oxígenos
y acá 6 por 16 oxígenos 6 más 8 es igual
a 14 mi ecuación ha sido balanceada a
muchas personas les cuesta trabajo pasar
de un 3 y medio para llegar a algo así
pero si empezamos con lo más difícil y
trabajamos átomo por átomo si al final
aparecen fracciones simplemente
multiplicamos ambos lados de la ecuación
por algún número que quite la fracción y
listo
hagamos otro tengo este óxido de hierro
más ácido sulfúrico produciendo todo
esto tan raro pero la clave aquí está en
darse cuenta de que este grupo el grupo
sulfato permanece igual ese o 4 aquí y
ese o 4 acá entonces podemos simplificar
las cosas si tomamos a esto como un solo
átomo hagamos una sustitución por él
si escribimos esto nuevamente lo pondré
en un color muy brillante
óxido de hierro
h 2 aquí hay un solo grupo sulfato
entonces escribimos x y eso produce
dos hierros y esta molécula tiene un
tres en el grupo sulfato son tres
moléculas de este grupo y luego más agua
todo lo que hice fue reemplazar el grupo
sulfato por equis y ahora podemos tratar
a x como si fuera un átomo veamos del
lado izquierdo cuantos hierro tenemos
hay dos hierros aquí y dos hierros acá
así que a primera vista los hierros
están balanceados ahora vamos con los
oxígenos aquí tenemos tres oxígenos lo
pondré en otro color tres oxígenos y acá
solo tenemos un oxígeno recuerden a día
algunos oxígenos en el grupo x pero para
simplificar el problema tomamos al grupo
sulfato que permanece igual por lo que
estos oxígenos quedan por separado
queremos tener 3 oxígenos del lado
derecho ponemos un 3 aquí y finalmente
vamos a ver a los hidrógenos cuántos
hidrógenos tenemos aquí hay 6 hidrógenos
del lado derecho 6 hidrógenos aquí y
queremos tener 6 hidrógenos acá entonces
necesitamos 3 de estas moléculas y
finalmente vamos con el grupo sulfato la
equis tenemos 3x aquí y por suerte para
nosotros hay 3x de este lado la ecuación
ha quedado balanceada y si queremos
escribirla en términos de sulfato
podemos simplemente volver a sustituir x
nos queda
una molécula de óxido de hierro más tres
moléculas de ácido sulfúrico h2so4 sólo
estoy sustituyendo la equis por s o 4 y
esto produce una de estas moléculas
s 43 sólo cambió la equis
tres moléculas de agua hagamos uno más
de óxido de carbono más hidrógeno
gaseoso produce metano más agua
trabajemos primero con los carbonos
tengo un carbono aquí un carbono acá los
carbonos están felices ahora veamos el
oxígeno 2 oxígenos aquí un oxígeno acá
para que sean 2 oxígenos pondré un 2
aquí y he dejado los hidrógenos al final
porque como no afecta a otros átomos es
más fácil jugar así de hidrógeno tengo 2
aquí y luego hay 4 hidrógeno saca 4
hidrógenos de acá entonces necesito 8
hidrógenos del lado izquierdo así que
pondré un 4
hemos terminado de balancear espero les
haya sido útil